welcome back to new rockstars i'm tommy
beck told him the finale of the extended
season 10 of the walking dead gave us
one
hell of an origin story from everybody's
favorite villain
negan oh he's so evil ah god you hate
him but you kind of love him and that
makes you feel conflicted this episode
actually gave us more insight into the
character than the comics
ever did but as the show off it does
some big changes were made in the
transition from the page to the screen
we've seen some negan changes before
like how in the comics negan only bats
glenn to death
glenn but on the show he gives the skull
thumping to both glenn and abraham
after viewing the season 10 finale we've
got some more changes to negan's story
let's dive in
first things first negan's trademark
leather jacket was given a proper origin
story on the show
negan dropped 600 bucks on a jacket and
lucille isn't happy about it let me tell
you if you're spending 600 bucks on a
jacket
it better be a buffalo bills vintage
starter jacket otherwise
you're paying too much and also let's
talk about the fact that you need to
talk through
big financial decisions with your life
partner but it's just a trick she hides
the leather jacket in a crawl space
making it the perfect gift
post-apocalypse and are we all looking
for the perfect gift for our lovers
as soon as the apocalypse is upon us you
know for me maybe it's a dozen roses or
a flamethrower in the comics he just
kind of gets his jacket
by grabbing it from a stories passing
through one day speaking of the comics
version of negan this video is brought
to you by the walking dead survivors the
brand new mobile game available for
pre-order now from the link in the
video's description the game's storyline
is pulled directly from the original
robert kirkman comics so you encounter
all the iconic characters like rick
michonne and even glenn he's back and
he's in this game you live through
classic moments and visit fan favorite
locations all within the world
think you could survive and build a
community in the walking dead universe
then prove it tough guy
in the walking dead survivors you gather
supplies explore new territory recruit
new heroes and become the leader of a
settlement you also kill lots of walkers
of course so that sounds like fun
the game allows for all kinds of
strategy whether you want to focus on
diplomacy and building a clan with other
players
go on the offensive and take the fight
to negan and his saviors build an army
and fortify your base though whatever
you do
remember the ultimate zombie lesson the
walkers are dangerous but it's the other
survivors that are the real threat it's
the kind of paranoid distrustful of
humanity mindset that has
kept me going for years and the zombie
apocalypse hasn't even happened yet i
have so much bottled water at my house
guys
please come drink some of my water with
me follow the game on social media from
the links in the description to see any
updates and you can download the game at
the link below
on the tv show lucille the bat also gets
an extended origin story lucille the bat
comes from laura she wants to make sure
that negan can defend himself as he
makes his way back to lucille in the
comics he just gets the bat from a
random dead person well the comics are
really just like
negan do your thing we want to find you
when you're evil we don't want to find
out what led you to that point
like the leather jacket this iconic item
has given much more meaning on the show
the saviors have an altered origin story
on the show as well negan runs into
laura
and her father franklin who is a doctor
he's trying to get some meds for
lucille's cancer and they help him out
and then he of course
sells them out to save his own ass
typical negan he comes back to save them
after he finds out his wife is dead and
thus begins the terrible journey of the
saviors
in the comics negan runs into dwight who
invites him back to his camp this is the
group he winds up taking over and
turning into the saviors
in the comics negan is unable to kill
his wife lucille after she dies of
cancer in the hospital
and turns into a walker so he gets a boy
in the hospital to do the deed for him
in a later one-shot comic titled negan
lives released in july of 2020
negan returns to the hospital to collect
his wife's bones and lay them to rest
like
any good husband would after your wife
has been turned into a zombie and you
hire some kid to kill her romance isn't
dead but lucille certainly is
as we saw in the show lucille overdoses
on pills to make sure that she's no
longer a burden to negan as he keeps
risking
everything to keep her alive negan is
unable to dispatch his dead wife up
close and personal so he burns the whole
house down instead you want to know what
love is let negan show you burning down
the house for the ones you love
negan's future on the show looks to be
very different from what we know in the
comics in the season finale we saw carol
take negan out to a secluded cabin in
the middle of the woods
she says the alexandria council voted to
exile him though in a feature for the
episode on amc plus showrunner angela
kang confirmed that the decision was
made by carol alone and not the council
very sneaky carol this will surely set
up some tension for season 11 as negan's
whereabouts become an issue for the town
of alexandria and certainly maggie in
the comics negan lives out a life of
solitude and personal exile the final
issue reveals that negan lives in a
house removed for the rest of the gang
in negan lives robert kirkman said he
was going to have maggie finally kill
negan but one of his artists and
collaborators talked him out of it we'll
just have to wait and see if the future
for negan and the walking dead show is a
killing blow from the ever resentful
maggie get em maggie you can support
this channel by checking out one of our
great merch options at
newrockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter
tommy bechtold follow new rockstars and
subscribe to new rockstars here on
youtube for breakdowns of
everything you love thanks so much for
watching see you next time
[Music]
you